Moana is packed with Disney and movie easter
eggs from Big Hero 6 to Zootopia, Frozen and
The Little Mermaid all the way through to
Mad Max: Fury Road.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to explain all
the easter eggs, hidden mickeys, in-jokes
and movie references I found in Moana.
Just before I start, I've got a very cool
giveaway for this awesome The Art of Moana
hardback book which features beautiful concept
art from the movie and fascinating details
about the making of the film.
For a chance to win, just subscribe and leave
a comment about the easter eggs on this video
or let me know about any other easter eggs
you spotted.
And as an extra thank-you to you for watching
this video, there's also some bonus ways to
enter the giveaway via the Gleam link in the
video description below!
Ok, quick warning: there are spoilers ahead
for the movie, so if you want to avoid those,
you check out my spoiler-free review of Moana
right here.
Moana directors Ron Clements and John Musker
are veteran Disney creators and there are
a bunch of easter eggs to their previous films
at Disney in Moana.
Let's start with The Little Mermaid because
there's some hidden symbolism in the locket
which Gramma Tala gives Moana that contains
the Heart of Te Fiti.
The heart and the locket call back to Ursula's
enchanted necklace which held Ariel's voice
captive and just as The Little Mermaid's story
is only resolved when Ariel's voice is restored
to her, so too Moana resolves her story by
restoring the Heart to Te Kā at the end of
the movie.
The circular swirl of the shell on Ursula's
necklace is also reflected in the circular
swirly symbolism scattered throughout Moana
such as on the gem itself, the ship sails,
the rock that Maui prised the Heart of Te
Fiti from, and the circular sand pattern when
the gem first reveals itself to Moana.
When Maui traps Moana in a cave with a huge
statue of himself at the end of his song "You're
Welcome", it's a nod to the statue of Prince
Eric that Ariel kept in her cave.
Later when Maui's statue topples over as Moana
uses it to climb out of the cave, a broken
piece from Maui's face, his nose, in fact,
bounces up into the screen, which is a little
hat tip to both the broken piece of Eric's
statue that was used to win Ariel over for
Ursula, and to the moment in Aladdin when
Jasmine and Aladdin fly by the pyramids on
the magic carpet and disturb one of the sculptors
who chips off the nose of an enormous sphinx
statue.
And, by the way, there's a neat parallel between
Ariel and Moana in that both their fathers
want them to stay within the limits of their
worlds: King Triton doesn't want Ariel to
go ashore and Chief Tui won't allow Moana
beyond the reef.
And Moana's story is like Ariel's in reverse
as Moana longs to leave the land for the sea,
while Ariel longs to leave the sea for the
land.
Plus, there's a nice nod to Ariel's hair flower
in the pink flower Moana wears in her hair.
And in the movie's end credits scene, there's
a brilliant shout-out to the crab Sebastian
from The Little Mermaid as well as a dig at
his accent.
In the scene, Tamatoa appears and he's still
stuck upside down on his back.
He pokes fun at himself and his "Shiny" song
and then says to the audience, "Still upside
down here!
Just need a little push!", before pausing
and then adding, "Can we be real?
If my name was Sebastian and I had a cool
Jamaican accent, you'd totally help me!
You would, you know you would!"
Moana's directors have also confirmed that
Ariel's sidekick, Flounder, appears in Moana
and I think I spotted him among the fish which
appear during the 2D animation section of
Maui's "You're Welcome" song.
As you can expect, there are some nice Frozen
easter eggs in the film, so make sure you
pay attention in Tamatoa's lair after Maui
recovers his fishhook as the demi-god has
difficulty shapeshifting and accidentally
switches into a number of different animals,
and one of them, which flashes by, is none
other than Kristoff's reindeer, Sven.
Clements and Musker also directed Aladdin,
and Maui's rapid shapeshifting into different
creatures in this scene tips its hat to the
Genie's fast and humorous transformations
as well as the various quick and funny transformations
that Aladdin's monkey Abu goes through.
And when Moana wakes up on Maui's island after
being ship-wrecked, her hair is all messed
up and full of sand, which is a nod to when
Anna woke up with big messed-up hair in Frozen.
As I'm sure you remember, snowman Olaf actually
loves summer and likes to imagine himself
sunbathing on the beach.
Now, we don't actually see him soaking up
the sun in Moana, as you can imagine what
would happen to him if he did that, but Moana's
directors have said that he is hidden in the
film, so keep your eyes peeled for what would
be left of a snowman if he went in the sun,
for example, his carrot nose.
And Moana screenwriter, Jared Bush, pokes
a bit of fun at the idea of Disney princesses
when Moana states that she is not a princess,
but Maui replies that, "If you wear a dress
and you have an animal sidekick, you're a
princess."
Moana's directors are also behind Disney's
1997 animated feature, Hercules, so it's intriguing
that Maui's backstory is a reverse of Hercules'
backstory.
Maui was a mortal who was abandoned by his
human parents and taken in by gods who made
him a demi-god.
But Hercules, however, had gods as parents
but ended up being raised by humans after
he was abandoned on earth by Hades' minions.
And, in a nice bit of coincidence, Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson, who's the voice of Maui,
also played the role of Hercules in the 2014
live-action movie of the same name.
The funny line where Maui interrupts Moana
as she's addressing him as "Maui, shapeshifter,
demi-god of the wind and sea" and he tells
her that she needs to add "Hero of Men…
and Women" to her list of epithets for him
could be a nod to the moniker of "The People's
Champion" that Dwayne Johnson took on during
his wrestling days.
Mini-Maui, who's Maui's tattoo sidekick and
acts as the demi-god's conscience, brings
to mind the character of Jiminy Cricket, who
was the conscience of Pinocchio in Disney's
famous film from 1940.
There's an amusing pop culture reference to
Twitter when Maui grabs Heihei and uses his
beak to sign Moana's oar saying that, "When
you use a bird to write with, it's called
tweeting."
And when Moana lands on top of Maui as they
jump into the Realm of Monsters, it's an interesting
call-back with a twist to The Princess And
The Frog, which was made by Moana directors
Clements and Musker.
In this film, Maui lands first and thinks
he's all OK, but then Moana comes crashing
down on top of him.
And in The Princess And The Frog, Tiana and
Naveen are suspended in air by some balloons
which burst sending Tiana crashing down first.
She's caught by a spider's web and thinks
she's safe, until Naveen comes crashing down
on top of her.
And it's in Lalotai where we're introduced
to Tamatoa, the huge self-absorbed crab who
likes to collect and adorn himself with hundreds
of shiny objects.
The character is reminiscent of The Collector
in Marvel's movies, who's portrayed by Benecio
del Toro, and, like Tamatoa, is a shady character
who likes to collect special objects.
There's also a hint of The Hobbit's dragon
Smaug, specifically Peter Jackson's film The
Desolation of Smaug, about Tamatoa in the
way they both cover themselves in the hordes
of treasure they've amassed in their lair
deep within a mountain, and in the way that,
at first, both Bilbo Baggins and Moana don't
even realise they're walking on top of Smaug
and Tamatoa until the creatures emerge from
underneath their treasure.
Tamatoa's fantastic song "Shiny" is heavily
influenced by David Bowie, and Jemaine Clement,
who voices the enormous crab, actually played
David Bowie in an episode of his TV comedy
series Flight of the Conchords.
As Tamatoa raises himself up in his lair,
a number of shiny artefacts that he's been
collecting fall off him and one of them looks
suspiciously like a rocket, which could be
a nod to Disney's 1991 adventure movie, The
Rocketeer, which they're currently developing
a sequel to.
The monsters that we see glimpses of in Lalotai
originate from Polynesian legends of Maui.
For example, there's an eight-eyed bat who
Maui once killed when the bat tried to steal
Maui's wife Kumu-lama.
And there was a giant eel which represents
the eel god Tuna-roa, which Maui has killed
in various legends.
The Kakamora sequence is a cross between Gremlins
and Mad Max: Fury Road.
In fact, the directors have said they specifically
wanted to pay homage to director George Miller
and his critically acclaimed Mad Max sequel.
And there's a moment when Moana lands on the
deck of one of the Kakamora boats and they
all suddenly turn and face her.
Well, hidden among the Kakamora is a very
crafty easter egg to the lovable robot Baymax
from Big Hero 6.
Moana directors Ron Clements and John Musker
have cameo'd in many of their previous Disney
films, and it looks like they might be hidden
among the Kakamora too.
If you stay through the whole credits, you'll
not only get to see the awesome Tamatoa post-credits
scene, but you'll also get to see a visual
shoutout to Disney's next animated feature,
Wreck-It Ralph 2.
Just make sure you watch the little tapestries
that scroll by during the credits as there's
a Wreck-It Ralph picture in one them, on the
right-hand side of the screen, right towards
the end of the movie.
And given that there were a number of Moana
easter eggs in Zootopia, it's hardly surprising
to find an easter egg to Disney's last animated
hit in Moana, especially since the two films
were written by Jared Bush.
Remember in Zootopia there was a very funny
Moana easter egg via the Meowana bootlegged
Blu-ray that Weaselton was selling on his
stall.
And there was also an easter egg to Maui's
fishhook on the back of Finnick's van.
Well, the Zootopia easter egg in Moana takes
the form of the slow-talking, fast-driving
sloth, Flash.
Moana's directors have said that Flash appears
in disguise which makes this creature here,
who appears in the Realm of Monsters sequence,
a very good candidate to be Flash.
Notice he's got four claws, like Flash's,
on each limb.
When the ocean first reaches out to Moana
as a sentient character in the movie, it's
reminiscent of the alien water tentacle from
James Cameron's 1989 sci-fi movie The Abyss.
And the ocean also has a sense of Aladdin's
magic carpet about it, in that it's a non-speaking
character that helps out Moana and guides
her forward in her quest.
There's a nod to Pixar's Crush and Squirt
in the scenes with toddler Moana when she's
on the beach and helps a baby turtle like
Squirt across the sand safely to the water;
and the baby turtle also swims by later with
a much larger turtle, who's similar to Crush
from Finding Nemo and Finding Dory.
And that lovely moment when toddler Moana
gently takes a leaf and uses it to shield
the baby turtle to help it to the sea is also
a little easter egg to the photo of Stitch
doing the same during the credits of Lilo
& Stitch.
And there's another hat tip to Lilo & Stitch
when Moana gets embarrassed about eating pork
in front of her pet pig Pua, which calls to
mind Lilo explaining why she couldn't feed
a tuna sandwich to her pet fish Pudge.
There's also a recurring in-joke about eating
Heihei, for example, one of the villagers
wants to cook him as he thinks the rooster
is too stupid to survive, which is a reference
to the fact that Heihei was almost scrapped
from Moana as the filmmakers were struggling
to make the character work in the story.
In fact, the day they figured out how to keep
Heihei in the movie, they all celebrated with
a meal of fried chicken, which means that
Moana eating pork in front of Pua is also
another in-joke about this!
After Te Fiti's heart is returned, there's
a sequence where the mother island is restored
to life and in these shots of the island's
vegetation, there's what looks like the magical
golden flower from Tangled.
Which seems very appropriate as the magical
flower is associated with healing and life.
The character of Gramma Tala, whose spirit
becomes a ray in the ocean, is analogous to
Grandmother Willow in Pocahontas in that she
serves as a voice of wisdom and as someone
who can guide the young heroine of the story.
And Gramma Tala's question to Moana "is there
something you want to hear?", which basically
means that Moana already knows her heritage
and what she should do, is an echo of Willow's
advice to Pocahontas to listen to the spirits
and Willow's words that 'you know your path,
child, now follow it.'
By the way, there's a nod back to the brilliant
short Inner Workings which plays before Moana
when Moana yells at the ocean that "Fish pee
in you all day", and also when she thinks
she's found a warm current in the sea, but
it's actually because Maui's just pee'd in
it.
If you remember, in Inner Workings, there's
a funny moment when the main character Paul
runs into the sea and we see his bladder give
a big smile and sigh, a cheeky joke about
Paul peeing in the sea.
There is a nice Hidden Mickey that you can
see just briefly in the scene which introduces
us to Tamatoa and his lair.
There are 3 pearls positioned on the sand
just below Tamatoa that look like the classic
Mickey Mouse silhouette.
You can also see a similar Mickey on the character
poster for Tamatoa in the positioning of 3
pearls in a canoe to the right of Tamatoa.
And there seem to be a few hidden mickeys
snuck in to the Kakamora scenes.
They're a little difficult to spot among all
the action going on during their attack, but
here are a few (possible) ones I spotted.
In this shot, there seems to be a pair of
hidden Mickeys in the barrels or drums stacked
up on one of the Kakamora boats.
Each mickey has two Kakamora standing on top
of what would be the ears in the mickey.
And the way these coconuts are stacked also
look like another hidden mickey.
I'm sure there are more hidden secrets tucked
away in these manically busy Kakamora scenes
that we'll have to wait for the Blu-ray to
spot!
Now, I'd love to know what other easter eggs
and references you spotted that I missed!
And how does Moana compare with your other
favourite Disney movies?
Let me know in the comments below!
Don't forget to subscribe and comment for
your chance to win this gorgeous The Art of
Moana hardback book.
If you enjoy finding easter eggs in Disney
movies, check out my Zootopia easter eggs
video.
And, I've got more Moana videos for you including
my review, my top 5 moments, and amazing facts
about the making of the movie!
Click or tap on either of the links here to
check those out.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!